The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I guess
we should start.
This is the last of
these lectures.
The final will be on next
Wednesday, as I hope you all
know by this time, in the ice
rink, whatever that means.
And there was some question
about how many sheets of paper
you could bring in
as crib sheets.
And it seems like the reasonable
thing is four
sheets, which means you can
bring in the two sheets you
made up for the quiz
plus two more.
Or you can make up four new
ones if you want or do
whatever you want.
I don't think it's very
important how many sheets you
bring in, because I've never
seen anybody referring to
their sheets.
I mean, it's a good way of
organizing what you know to
try to put it on four
sheets of paper.
I want to mostly review what
we've done throughout the
term, with a few more general
comments thrown in.
I thought I'd start with
martingales, because we then
completely finish what
we wanted to
talk about last time.
And the Strong Law of
Large Numbers was
left slightly hanging.
And I want to show you
how to do that in a
little better way.
And also show you that it's a
more general theorem than it
appears to be at first sight.
So let's go with martingales.
The basic definition is a
sequence of random variables
is a martingale, if, for all
elements of the sequence, the
expected value of Zn, given all
of the previous values, is
equal to the random variable,
Z n minus 1.
Remember, and we've talked about
this a number of times,
when you're talking about the
expected value of one random
variable, given a bunch of other
random variables, you're
only taking the expectation
over the first part.
You're only taking the
expectation over Z sub n.
And the other quantities are
still random variables.
Namely, you have an expected
value Z sub n, for each sample
value of Z n minus 1, all
the way down to Z 1.
And what the definition says is
it's a martingale only if,
for all sample values of those
earlier values, the expected
value is equal to the sample
value of the most recent one.
Namely, the memory is all
contained right in this last
term, effectively.
At least as far as expectation
is concerned.
Memory might be far broader than
that for everything else.
And the first thing we did with
martingales is we said
the expected value was again,
if you're only given part of
the history, if you're only
given the history from i back
to 1, where i is strictly less
than n minus 1, that expected
value is equal to Zi.
So no matter where you start
going back, the expected value
of Z sub n is the most recent
value that is given.
So if the most recent value
given is Z 1, then the
expected value of Zn,
given Z1, is Z1.
And also along with that, you
have the relationship, the
expected value of Zn is equal
to the expected value of Zi,
just by taking the expected
value over Z sub i.
So all of that's sort
of straightforward.
We talked a good deal about
the increments of a
martingale.
The increments, X sub n equals
Z sub n minus Zn minus 1, are
very much like the increments
that we have when a renewal
process, when a Poisson
process, all of these
processes we talked about we
can define in various ways.
And here we can define a
martingale in two ways also.
One is by the actual martingale
itself, which are,
in a sense, the sums
of the increments.
And the other ways in terms
And the increments satisfy the
property that the expected
value of Xn, given all the
earlier values, is equal to 0.
Namely, no matter what are all
the earlier values are, X sub
n has mean 0 in order
to be a martingale.
A good special case of this is
where X sub n is equal to U
sub n times Y sub n, where the
U sub n are IID, equiprobable
1 and minus 1.
And the Y sub i's are anything
you want them to be.
It's just that the U sub i's
have to be independent
of the Y sub i.
So I think this shows that in
fact martingales are really a
pretty broad class of things.
And they were invented to talk
about fair gambling games,
where they wanted to give the
gambler the opportunity to do
whatever he wanted to do.
But the game itself was defined
in such a way that, no
matter what you do,
the game is fair.
You establish bets in one
whatever things you want to.
And when you wind up with it,
the expected value of X sub n,
given the past, is always 0.
And that's equivalent to saying
the expected value of Z
sub n, given the past,
is equal to Z sub i.
Examples we talked about are 0
mean random walks and products
of unit-mean IID random
variables.
So they're both these product
martingales, and there are
these sum martingales.
And those are just two simple
examples, which
come up all the time.
Then we talked about
submartingales.
A submartingale is like
a martingale, except
it grows with time.
And we're not going to talk
about supermartingales,
because a supermartingale is
just a negative submartingale.
So we don't have to
talk about that.
A martingale is a
submartingale.
So anything you know about
submartingales applies to
martingales also.
So you can state theorems for
submartingales and they apply
to martingales just as well.
You can say stronger things very
often about martingales.
And then we have the same
theorem for submartingales.
Now that should say, and it did
say, until my evil twin
got a hold of it, if Zn is a
submartingales, then for n
greater than i, greater than
0, this expected value is
greater than or equal to Zi.
And the expected value Zn is
greater than equal to the
expected value of Zi.
In other words, this theorem,
for submartingales, is the
same as the corresponding
theorem for martingales,
except now you have inequalities
there, just like
you have inequalities in
the definition of the
submartingales.
So there's nothing
strange there.
Then we found out that, if you
have a convex function, from
the reals into the reals, then
Jensen's inequality says that
the expected value of h of X is
greater than or equal to h
of the expected value of x.
We showed a picture for
that you remember.
There's a convex curve.
There's some straight line.
And what Jensen's inequality
says is you take an average
over the expected value
of X, and you're
somewhere above the line.
And you take the average
first, and you're
sitting on the line.
So if h of X is convex, that's
what Jensen's inequality is.
And it follows from that that,
if Zn is a submartingale--
and that includes
martingales--
and h is convex and the expected
value of h of X is
finite, then h of Zn is
a martingale also.
In other words, if you have
a martingale Z sub n, the
expected value of Z sub
n is a submartingale.
The expected value of E to
R Zn is a martingale.
Use whatever convex function you
want to, and you wind up,
martingales go into
submartingales.
You can't get out of the range
of submartingales that easily.
We then talked about stopped
martingales and stopped
submartingales.
We said a stopped process,
for a possibly
defective stopping time--
now you remember what
a stopping time is?
A stopping time is a random
variable, which is a function
of everything that takes place
up until the time of stopping.
And you have to look at the
definition carefully, because
stopping time comes in too many
places to just say it and
understand what it means.
But it's clear what it means,
if you view yourself as an
observer watching a sequence of
random variables, of sample
values of random variables,
one after another.
And after you see a certain
number of random variables,
your rule says, stop.
And then you don't
observe anymore.
So you just observe this
finite number.
And then you stop
at that point.
And then you're all done.
If it's a possibly defective
stopping rule, then you might
keep on going forever,
or you might stop.
You don't know what you're
going to do.
The stopped process Z sub n
star is a little different
from what we were
doing before.
Before what we were doing
is we were sitting there
observing this process.
At a certain point, the stopping
rule said stop.
And before, we were
very obedient.
And when the stopping rule told
us to stop, we stopped.
Now, since we know a little
more, we question authority a
little more.
And when the stopping rule says
stop, we break things
into two processes.
There's the original process,
which keeps on going.
And there this stopped process,
which just stops.
And it's convenient to have a
stopped process instead of
just a stopping rule.
Because with a stopped process,
you can look at any
time into the future, and if
it's already stopped, you know
what the stopped value is.
You know what it was
when it stopped.
You don't necessarily know when
it stopped, by looking at
in the future.
But you know that it did stop.
So the stopped process, well,
it says here what it is.
It satisfies the stopped value
at time n as equal to Z sub n,
if n is less than or equal to
the stopping time J, and Z sub
n star is equal to Z sub J,
if n is greater than J.
So you get up to the stopping
timing, and you stop.
And then it just stays
fixed forever after.
And the nice theorem there is
that the stopped process for a
submartingale, with a possibly
defective stopping rule, is a
submartingale again.
What that means is it's just a
concise way of writing, the
stopped process for a martingale
is a martingale in
its own right.
And the stopped process for
a submartingale is a
submartingale in
its own right.
So the convenient thing is, you
can take a martingale, you
can stop it, you still
have a martingale.
And everything you know about
martingales applies to this
stopping process.
So we're getting to the point
where, starting out with a
martingale, we can do lots
of things with it.
And that's the whole
mathematical game.
With a mathematical
game, you build up
theorems from nothing.
As an experimentalist or an
engineer, you sort of try to
figure out those things from
the reality around you.
Here, we're just
building it up.
And the other part of that
theorem says that the expected
value of Z1 is less than or
equal to the expected value of
Zn star, is less than or equal
to the expected value of Zn
for a submartingale.
And they're all equal
to a martingale.
In other words, the marginal
expectations for a martingale,
they start out a Z1.
They stay at Z1.
And for the stopped process,
they stay at that same value.
And that's not too surprising.
Because if you have a
martingale, if you go until
you reach the stopping point,
from that stopping point on,
the martingale has mean
0, from that point on.
Not the martingale itself,
but the increments of the
martingale have mean 0,
from that point on.
And the stopped process
has mean 0.
In other words, the stopped
process, the increments are
actually 0.
Whereas for the original
process, the
increments wobble around.
But they still have mean 0.
So this is a very nice and
useful thing to know.
If you look at this product
martingale, Z sub n is E to
the rsn minus n gamma or r .
Why is that a martingale?
How do you know it's
a martingale?
Well, you look at the expected
value of this.
And it's expected
The expected value of E to rsn
is the moment generating
function of Z sub
n, of s sub n.
It's moment generating
function of E to rsn.
And the moment generating
function of E to rsn is just E
to the n gamma of r.
So this is clearly something
which should be a martingale,
because it just keeps at
that level all along.
If you have a stopping rule,
such as a threshold crossing,
then you've got a stopped
martingale.
And subject to some little
mathematical nitpicks, which
the text talks about, this leads
you to the much more
general version of Wald's
identity, which says that the
expected value of Z, at the time
of stopping, is equal to
the expected value of
E to the rsJ minus J
gamma of r equals 1.
This you remember is what Wald's
identity was when we
were just talking about
random walks.
And this was a more general
version, because it's talking
about general stopping rules,
instead of just to thresholds.
But it does have these little
mathematical nitpicks in it,
which I'm not going to
talk about here.
Then we have Kolmogorov's
submartingale inequality.
We talked about all of these
things last time.
So we're going pretty quickly
through them.
The submartingale inequality
is really the Markov
inequality souped up.
And what it says is, if you
have a non-negative
submartingale, that can
include a non-negative
martingale, for any positive
integer m, the probability
that the maximum is a Z sub i,
from 1 to m, is greater than
or equal to a, is less than or
equal to the expected value of
Z sub m over a.
You see all that the Markov
inequality says is the
probability that Z sub m is
greater than or equal to a, is
less than or equal to this.
This puts a lot more teeth into
it, because it lets you
talk about all of these random
variables, up until time m.
And it says the maximum
of them satisfies this
inequality.
I mean, we always knew that
the Markov inequality was
very, very weak.
And this is also pretty weak.
But it's not quite as
weak, because it
covers a lot more things.
If you have a non-negative
martingale--
this is submartingales,
this is martingales.
You see here, with
submartingales, the expected
value of Z sub m keeps
increasing with m.
So there's a trade-off between
making m large and
not making m large.
If you're dealing with a
martingale, then expected
value Z sub m is constant
over all time.
It doesn't change.
And therefore, you can take
this inequality here.
You can go to the limit,
as m goes to infinity.
And you wind up with a
probability, the sup of Zm,
greater than or equal to a, is
less than or equal to the
expected value of the first of
those random variables, the
expected value of
Z1 divided by a.
So this looks like a very
powerful inequality.
It turns out that I don't know
many applications of that.
And I don't know why.
It seems like it ought
to be very useful.
But I know one reason, which is
what I'm going to show you
next, which is how you can
really use the submartingale
inequality to make it do an
awful lot of things that you
wouldn't imagine that it
could do otherwise.
First, you go to the Kolmogorov
version of the
Chebyshev inequality.
This has the same relationship
to the Kolmogorov
submartingale inequality as
Chebyshev has to Markov.
Namely, what you do is, instead
of looking at the
random variables Z sub n, you
look at the random variable Z
sub n squared.
And what do we know now?
If Z sub n is a martingale or
a submartingale, Z sub n
squared is a martingale
or submartingale also.
Namely, well, the only thing
we can be sure of is that Z
sub n squared is a
submartingale.
But if it's a submartingale,
then we can apply this
inequality again.
And what it tells us, in this
case, is the probability at
the maximum of the magnitudes
of these random variables.
Probably the maximum is greater
than or equal to b, is
less than or equal to the
expected value of Z sub m
squared over b squared.
So before, just like the Markov
inequality, the Markov
inequality only works for
non-negative random variables.
You go to the Chebyshev
inequality, because that works
for negative or positive
random variables.
So that makes it kind of neat.
And then what you have is this
thing, which goes down as 1
over b squared, which looks
a little stronger.
But that's not the real reason
that you want to use it.
Now, this inequality here only
works for the first m values
of this random variable.
What we're usually interested
in here is what happens as m
gets very large.
As m gets very large, this
thing, very often, blows up.
So this [INAUDIBLE]
does not really do what
you would like an
inequality to do.
So what we're going to do is,
first, we're going to say, if
you had this inequality here,
then you can lower bound this
by taking just a maximum, not
over 1 up to m, but only over
m over 2 up to m.
Now why do we want to do that?
Well, hold on and you'll see.
But anyway this is bigger
than, greater than
or equal to, this.
So what we're going to do now
is we're going to take this
inequality.
We're going to use it for m
equals 2 to the m, for m
equals 2 to the k plus 1, m
equals 2 to the k plus 2, all
the way up to infinity.
And so we're going to find the
probability of the union over
j greater than or equal to k of
this quantity here, but now
just maximized over 2 to the j
minus 1, less than n, less
than or equal 2 to the j.
And then the maximum of Z sub
n, greater than or equal to.
And now, for each one of these
j's here, we'll put in
whatever b sub j we want.
So the general form of this
inequality then becomes.
We have this term on the left.
We use the union bound.
And we get this term
on the right.
So at this point, we have an
inequality, which works for
all n, instead of just
for values smaller
than some given amount.
So this is sort of a general
technique for taking an
inequality, which only works
up to a certain value, and
extending it so it works
over all values.
You have to be pretty careful
about how you choose b sub j.
Now what we're going
to do is say, OK.
And remember, what is happening
here is we started
out with a submartingale
or a martingale.
When we take Z n squared, we
still have a submartingale.
So we can use a submartingale
inequality, which is what
we're doing here.
We're using the submartingale
inequality on Zm squared
rather than on Zm.
And Zm squared is non-negative,
so that works there.
Then we go down to this point.
We take a union over
all of these terms.
And note what happens.
Every n is included in one
of these terms, every n
beyond 2 the k.
So if we want to prove something
about the limiting
values of Z sub n, we have
everything included there,
everything beyond 2 to the k.
But as far as the limit is
concerned, you don't care
about any initial finite set.
You care what happens after
that initial finite set.
So what we have then
[INAUDIBLE]
of these terms, less than
or equal to this term.
When I apply this to a random
walk S sub n, S sub n is a
submartingale, at this point.
The expected value
of x squared will
assume a sigma squared.
The expected value now S sub
n, or Z sub n is we'll call
it, is the sum of these n
IID random variables.
So the expected value--
AUDIENCE: 10 o'clock.
PROFESSOR: The expected value
of Z to the 2J is just 2 to
the J times the expected value
of x squared, in other words,
sigma squared.
[INAUDIBLE] just doing this
for a 0 mean [INAUDIBLE]
variable, because [INAUDIBLE]
given an arbitrary
non-0 [INAUDIBLE]
random variable.
You can look at it as to
mean plus a random
variable, which is 0 mean.
So that's the same ideas
we're using here.
So we take this inequality now,
and I'm going to use for
b sub J, 3/2 to the
J. Why 3/2 to J?
Well you'll see in
just a second.
But when I use 3/2 to the J here
I get the maximum over S
sub n, greater than or equal
to 3/2 to the J.
And over here I get b sub J
squared is 9/4 to the J. And
here I have 2 the J also.
So when I sum this, it winds up
with 8/9 to the k times 9
sigma squared.
So what I have now is something
where, when k gets
larger, this term
is going to 0.
And I have something over here,
well that doesn't look
quite so attractive, but
just wait a minute.
What I'm really interested
in is not S sub n.
But I'm interested in
S sub n over n.
For the strong law of large
numbers, I'd like to show that
S sub n over n approaches
a limit.
And n in this case runs between
2 to the J minus 1 and
2 to the J.
So when I put that in here--
we'll see what that amounts
to in the next slide.
For the strong law of large
numbers, what our theorem says
is that the probability of the
set of sample points, for
which S sub n over n equals 0,
that set of sample points has
probability y.
So the proof of that, if I pick
up this equation from the
previous slide, and when I lower
bound the left side of
this, what I'm going to get, I'm
going to divide by n here.
And I'm going to divide by
something a little bit
smaller, which is 2 to
the J minus 1 here.
So I get the maximum of S sub
n over n, greater than or
equal to 2 times 3/4 to the J.
Now you see why I picked--
I think you see at this
point why I picked the
sub j the way I did.
I wanted to pick it t to be
smaller than 2 to the J. And I
wanted to pick it to be big
enough that it drove the right
hand term to 0.
So now we're done really.
Because, if I look at this
expression here, a sample
sequence S sub n of omega,
that's not contained in this
union, has to approach 0.
Because these terms from 2 to
the J minus 1 to 2 to the J,
in order to be in this set, they
have to be greater than
or equal to 2 times
3/4 to the J.
As j gets larger and larger,
this term goes to 0.
So the only terms that exceed
that are terms that are
arbitrarily small.
So the complement of this set is
the set of terms for which
S sub n over n does
not approach 0.
But the probability of that is
8/9 to the k times time some
garbage over here.
So now it's true for all k.
The terms which approach 0,
namely the sampled values for
which S sub n over n approaches
0 are all
complimentary to this set.
So the probability that S sub n
over omega over n approaches
0 is greater than 1 minus
this quantity here.
That's true for all k.
And since it's true for all
k, this term goes to 0.
And the theorem is proven.
Now why did I want to
go through this.
There are perhaps easier ways
to prove the strong law of
large numbers, just assuming
that the variance is finite.
Why this particular y?
Well, if you look at this, it
applies to much more than just
sums of IID random variables.
It applies to arbitrary
martingales, so long as these
conditions are satisfied.
It applies to these cases, like
where you have a random
variable, which is plus or minus
1 times some arbitrary
random variable.
So this gives you sort of a
general way of proving strong
laws of large numbers
for strange
sequences of random variables.
So that's the reason for
going through this.
We now have a way of proving
strong laws of large numbers
for lots of different kinds of
martingales, rather than just
for this set of things here.
So let's move on back to Markov
chains, countable or
finite state.
I'm moving back to chapter three
and five in the text,
mostly chapter five, and trying
to finish some sort of
review of what we've done.
When I look back at what we've
done, it seems like we've
proven an awful lot theorems.
So all I can do is talk
about the theorems.
I should say something, again,
this last day, on this last
lecture, about why we spend so
much time proving theorems.
In other words, we've just
proven a theorem here.
I promised you I would prove a
theorem every lecture, along
with talking about why they're
important and so on.
And most of you are engineers
or you're scientists in
various fields.
You're not mathematicians.
Why should you be interested
in all these theorems.
Why should you take abstract
courses, which
look like math courses?
And the reason is this kind of
stuff is more important for
you than it is for
mathematicians.
And it's more important for
you, because when you're
dealing with a real engineering
or real scientific
problem, how do you
deal with it?
I mean, you have a real
mess facing you.
You spend a lot of time trying
to understand what that mess
is all about.
And you don't form a model of
it, and then apply theorems.
What you do is to try
to understand it.
You look at multiple models.
When we were looking at
hypothesis testing, we said
we're going to assume a
priori probabilities.
I lied about that
a little bit.
We we're not assuming a
priori probabilities.
We we're assuming a class of
probability models, each of
which had a priori probabilities
in them.
And then we said something
about that class of
probability models.
And saying something about
that class of probability
models, we were able to say a
great deal more than you can
say if you refuse to even think
about a model, which
doesn't have a priori
probabilities in it.
So by looking at lots of
different models, you can
understand an enormous number
of things without really
having any one model which
describes the whole
situation for you.
And that's why we try to prove
theorems for models, because
then, when you understand lots
of simple models, you have
these complicated physical
situations, and
you play with them.
You play with them by applying
various simple models that you
understand to them.
And as you do this, you
gradually understand the
physical process better.
And that's the way we
discover things.
OK, end of lecture.
Not end of lecture, but end of
partial lecture about why you
want to learn some
mathematics.
The first passage time from
state i to j, remember, is the
smallest n, when you start off
in state i, at which you get
to state j.
You start off in state i.
You jump from one lily
pad to another.
You eventually wind up
at lily pad number j.
And we want to know how long
it takes you to get to j.
That's a random variable,
obviously.
And this Tij, as possibly the
effective random variable,
that has the probability
mass function.
It's the definition of
what this probability
mass function is.
And it has a distribution
function.
And the probability
mass function--
you probably remember
how we derived this.
We derived it by sort of
crawling up on it, by looking
at it, first, for n equals 1,
in which case it's just a
transition probability
of n equals 2.
In which case, it's the
probability that you first go
to k, and then in n minus
1 steps, you go to j.
But you have to leave j out,
because if you go to j in the
first step, you've already
had your first passage.
so
We define a state to be
recurrent, if T sub jj is
non-defective.
And we define it to be
transient otherwise.
In other words, if it's not
certain that you ever get to
state j, then you define it
to be transient, if it's
recurrent and it's positive
recurrent, if the expected
value of T sub jj is
less than infinity.
And it's null recurrent
otherwise.
How do we know how
to analyze this?
Well we study renewal
processes.
And if you look at the renewal
process where you've got a
renewal every time you hit
state j, you start
out on stage j.
The first time you hit state
j, that's a renewal.
The next time you hit state
j, that's another renewal.
You have a renewal process where
the interrenewal time is
a random variable, which has
the PMF F sub ij event.
Excuse me, if you have a renewal
process, if you start
in state j, where T sub jj is
the amount of time before
renewal occurs, from that time
on, you get another renewal
with another random variable
with the same
distribution as Tjj.
And F sub ij is the PMF
of that renewal time.
And F sub ij is the distribution
function of it.
So then when we define the state
j as being recurrent,
what we're really doing is going
back to what we know
about renewal processes and
saying a Markov chain is
recurrent if the renewal process
that we define for
that countable state Markov
chain has these various
properties for this renewal
random variable.
For each recurrent j, there's
an integer renewal counting
process N sub jj of t.
You start in state j at time t,
which is after t steps of
the Markov process.
What you're interested is how
many times have you hit state
j, up until time t.
That's the counting process we
talk about in renewal theory.
So N sub jj of t is the number
of visits to j starting in j.
And it has the interrenewal
distribution F sub jj, which
is that quantity up there.
We have a delayed renewal
counting process N sub ij of
t, if we count visits
to j, starting in i.
We didn't talk much about
delayed renewal processes,
except for pointing out that
when you have a delayed
renewal process, it
really is the same
as a renewal processes.
It just has some arbitrary
amount of time that's required
to get to state j for the
first time and the keep
recurrent on.
Even if the expected time to
get to j for first time is
infinite, and the expected time
for renewals from j to j
is finite, you still have this
same renewal processes.
You can even lose an infinite
amount of time at the
beginning, and you amortize
it over time.
Don't ask me why you can
amortize an infinite amount of
time over time.
But you can.
And actually if you read about
delayed renewal processes, you
see why you actually get that.
So all states in a class are
positive recurrent, or all are
null recurrent, or all
are transient.
We've proved that theorem.
It wasn't really a very
hard theorem to prove.
And you can sort of see
that it ought to be.
Then we define the chain as
being irreducible, if all
state pairs communicate.
In other words, if for every
pair of states, there's a path
that goes from one state
to the other state.
This is intuitively a simple
idea, if you have a finite
state and Markov chain.
If you have a countably infinite
state Markov chain,
it seems to be a little
more peculiar.
But it really isn't.
For a countably infinite state
an Markov chain every state
has a finite number.
And you can take every
pair of states.
You can identify them.
And you can see whether there's
a path going from one
to the other.
For all of these birth-death
processes we've talked about,
I mean, it's obvious whether
the states all
communicate or not.
You just see if there's
any break in the
chain at any point.
And it really looks
like a chain.
It's a node, two transitions,
another node, two transitions,
another node.
And that's just the way chains
are supposed to work.
An irreducible class might
be positive recurrent.
It might be null recurrent.
Or it might be transient.
And we already have seen what
makes a state null recurrent
or transient.
And it's the same thing
for the class.
We started out by saying
a state is either null
recurrent, positive recurrent,
or transient depending on this
renewal process associated
with it.
And now there's this theorem,
which says that if one node in
a class of states is positive
recurrent, they all are.
And you ought to be able
to sort of see
the reason for that.
If I have one state which is
positive recurrent, it means
that the expected time to
go from this state to
this state is finite.
Now if I had some other
state, I have to go
from here to there.
I can go through here and
then off to there.
So the amount of time it takes
to get to there, and then from
there to there, is also finite,
expected amount, and
the same backwards.
So that was the way
we proved this.
If we have an irreducible
Markov chain--
now this is the theorem you
really use all the time.
This is sort of says how you
operate with these things.
It says the steady
state equations--
they're the equations you've
used in half the problems
you've done with
Markov chains--
if these equations have a
solution for the pi sub j's,
remember the Markov chain is
defined in terms of the
transition probabilities
P sub ij.
We solve these equations to find
out what the steady state
probabilities pi sub j are.
And the theorem says, if you can
find the solution to those
equations--
pi sub j's have to
add up to 1--
then the solution is unique.
The pi sub j's are equal to 1
over the mean time to go from
that state back to
that state again.
And what does that mean?
What that really gives you is
not a way to find pi sub j.
It gives you a way to
find a T sub jj.
Because these equations are more
often the way that you
solve for the steady state
probabilities.
And then that gives you a way
to find the mean recurrence
time between visits to
this given state.
And what else does
this theorem say?
It says if the states are
positive recurrent, then the
steady state equations
have a solution.
So this is an if and only
if kind of statement.
It relates these equations,
these steady state equations,
to solutions and says, if
these equations have a
solution, then in fact
you have the
steady state equations.
They satisfy all these
relationships about mean
recurrence time.
And if the states are positive
recurrent, then those
equations have a solution.
And in the solutions, the pi
sub j's are all possible.
So it's an infinite set of
equations, so you can't
necessarily solve it.
But you sort of know everything
there is to know
about it, at this point.
Well, there's one other thing,
when you have a birth-death
chain, these equations simplify
a great deal.
The counting processes under
positive recurrence have to
satisfy this equation.
And my evil twin brother got a
hold of this and left out the
n in the copy that you have.
And I spotted it when I looked
at it just a little bit.
He was still sleeping, so
I've managed to find it.
So it's corrected here.
And what does that say?
It says, when you have positive
recurrence, if you
look from 0 out to t, and you
count the number of times that
you hit state j, that's
a random variable.
If you take that and divide by
n, you look from time 0 out to
time N, N sub ij of N, it's
the number of times
you visit state j.
You divide that by N, and
you go to the limit.
And there's a strong law of
large numbers there, which was
a strong law of large numbers
for renewal processes, which
says that it has a limit
with probability 1.
And this says that limit
is pi sub j.
And that's sort of
obvious, again.
I mean, visualize
what happens.
You start out in state j.
For one unit of time,
you're in state j.
Then you go away from state j,
and for a long time you're out
in the wilderness.
And then you finally get
back to state j again.
Think of a renewal reward
process, where you get 1 unit
of reward every time you're in
state j and 0 reward every
time you're not in state j.
That means every interrenewal
period, you pick
up one unit of reward.
Well, this is what that says.
It says that the fraction of
those visits to state j--
that out of the total visits in
the Markov chain, the ones
that go to state j have
probability pi sub j.
So again this is another
relationship with these steady
state probabilities.
The steady state probabilities
tell you what these mean
recurrence times are.
And that tells you
what this is.
This, in a sense, is
the same as this.
Those are just sort of
the same results.
So there's nothing
special about it.
We talked a little bit about
the Markov model of age of
renewal process for any
integer valued renewal
process, you can find a Markov
chain which gives you the age
of that process.
You visualize being
in state j.
And you visualize being in state
0, of this Markov model,
at the point where you
have a renewal.
One step later, if you have
another renewal, that happens
with probability P sub 00, you
go back to state 0 again.
If you don't have a renewal
in the next time,
you go to state 1.
From state 1, you might
go to state 2.
When you're in state 2, it means
you're two time units
away from state 0.
If you go back to state 0, it
means you have a renewal in
three time units.
Otherwise you go to state 3.
Then you might have a renewal
and so forth.
So for this very simple kind
of Markov chain, this tells
you everything there is to
know, in the sense, about
integer value renewal
processes.
So there's this nice connection
between the two.
And it lets you see pretty
easily about when you have no
recurrence.
Now we spend a lot of time
talking about these
birth-death Markov chains.
And the easy way to solve for
birth-death Markov of chains
is to say intuitively that
between any two adjacent
states, the number of times
you go up has to equal the
number of times you go down,
plus or minus 1.
If you start out here and you
end up here, you're going this
way one more time than you've
gone that way and vice versa.
And combining that with the
steady state equations that we
now have been talking about,
it must be that the steady
state probability
of pi sub i--
pi sub i times P sub i is the
probability of going from
state 2 to state 3.
It's the probability of being
in state 2 and making a
transition to state 3.
This probability here is the
probability of being in state
3 and going to state 2.
And we're saying that
asymptotically, as you look
over an infinite number of
transitions, those two have to
be the same.
The other way to do it, if you
like algebra, is to start out
with a steady state equation.
And you can derive
this right away.
I think it's nicer to
see intuitively
why it has be true.
And what that says is if rho sub
i is equal to P sub i over
Q sub i plus 1, P sub i is the
up transition probability.
Q sub i is the down transition
probability.
Rho sub i is the ratio of the
two state probabilities.
And that's equal to this
equation here.
That's just how to calculate
these things.
And you've done that.
Let's go on to Markov
processes.
I have no idea where I'm
going to finish up.
I had a lot to do.
I better not waste
too much time.
Remember what a Markov
process is now.
At least the way we started
out thinking about, it's a
Markov chain along with
a holding time.
And each state is
a Markov chain.
And the holding times are
exponential, to be a countable
state Markov process.
So we can visualize it
as a sequence of
states, X0, X1, X2, X3.
And a sequence of holding
times, U1, U2, U3, U4.
these are all random
variables.
And this kind of dependence
diagram says what random
variables depend on what
random variables.
U1, given X0, is independent
of the rest of the world.
U2, given X1, is independent
of the rest of the
world, and so forth.
And if you look at this graph
here and you visualize the
fact that because of Bayes'
rule, you could go
both ways on this.
In other words, if this, given
this, is independent of
everything else, we
can go through the
same kind of argument.
And we can make these arrows
go the opposite way.
And we can say, if we just
consider these states here, we
can say that, given X3, U4 is
independent of X2 and also
independent of U3 and X1
and U2 and so forth.
So if you look at the dependence
graph of a Markov
chain, which is which states
depend on which other states,
those arrows there that we have,
which make it easier to
see what's going on, you
can take them off.
You can redraw them in any way
you want to and look at the
dependencies in the
opposite way.
Now to understand what the
state is at any time t,
there's an equation
to do that.
It's an equation that
isn't much help.
I think it's more help to look
at this and to see from this
what's going on.
You start in some
state that's 0.
And starting in state 0, there's
a holding time in U0.
The holding time is U1.
And you stay in.
And the time in U1 is an
exponential random variable
with rate U sub i.
That's what this says.
So at the end of that holding
time, you go from state i to
some other state.
This is the state you go to.
The state you go to is according
to the mark Markov
chain probabilities.
And it's state j in this case.
You stay in state j until the
holding time U2, which is a
function of j, finishes you up
at this time and so forth.
So if you want to look at what
state you're in at a given
time, namely pick a time here
and say what's the state at
this time, as a random
variable.
So what you have to do then is
you have to climb your way up
from here to there.
And you have to talk about the
value of S1, S2, and S3.
And those are exponential
random variables.
But they're exponential random
variables that depend on the
state that you're in.
So as you're climbing your way
up and looking at this sample
function of the process, you
have to look at U1 an X0.
X0 defines what U1 is,
as a random variable.
It says that U1 is an
exponential random variable,
with rate U sub i.
So you get to here, then you
have some holding time here,
which is a function of j and
so forth, the whole way up.
Which is why I said that an
equation for X of t, in terms
of these S's is not going to
help you a great deal.
Understanding how the process
is working I think
helps you a lot more.
We said that there were three
ways to represent a Markov
process, which I'm giving
here in terms
just of Markov chains.
The first one--
and the fact that these are all
for M/M/1 doesn't make any
difference.
It's just these three
general [INAUDIBLE].
One of them is, you look at it
in terms of the embedded
Markov chain.
For this embedded Markov
chain, the transition
probabilities, when you're in
state 0 in an M/M/1 queue,
what's the next state
you go to?
Well the only state you
can go to is state 1.
Because we don't have any
self transitions.
So you go up to state
1 eventually.
From state 1, you can go that
way, with probability mu over
lambda plus mu.
Or you can go this way, with
probability lambda over lambda
plus mu, and so forth
the whole way out.
The next way of describing it,
which is almost the same, is
instead of using the transition
probabilities and
the embedded chain, you look
directly at the transition
rates for the Poisson process.
Meaning the transition rates are
the new sub i's associated
with the different states.
When you get in state i, the
amount of time you spend is
state i is an exponential
random variable.
And when you make a transition,
you're either
going to go to one state or
another state, in this case.
In general, you might go to any
one of a number of states.
Now if I tell that we start out
in state one and the next
state we go is state 2, now I
ask you what's the expected
amount of time that that
transition took?
What's the answer?
Is it queue 1, 2, or
is it mu sub 1?
Anybody awake out there?
AUDIENCE: Sir, could you
repeat the question?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
The question is, we started
out in state 1.
Given that we started out in
state 1 and given that the
next state is state 2, what's
the amount of time that it
takes to go from 1 to 2?
It's an exponential
random variable.
What's the rate of that
random variable?
AUDIENCE: Lambda plus U.
PROFESSOR: What?
PROFESSOR: Lambda plus mu?
Yes.
Lambda plus mu in the
case of M/M/1 queue.
If you have an arbitrary change,
why the amount of time
that it takes is mu sub I. This
is just back to this old
thing about splitting and
combining of Poisson processes.
When you have a combined Poisson
process, which is what
you have here, when you're in
state i, there's a combined
Poisson process, which is
running, which says you go
right with probability.
Lambda, you go left with
probability mu
for an M/M/1 queue.
And you can look at it in terms
of, first, you see what
the next state is.
And then you ask how long did
it take to get there?
Or you look at in terms of how
long does it take to make a
transition and then which
state did you go to?
And with these combined Poisson
processes, those two
questions are independent
of each other.
And if there's one thing you
remember from all of this,
please remember that.
Because it's something that
you use in almost every
problem that you do with Markov
chains and Markov processes.
It just comes up all the time.
This final version here is
looking at the same Markov
process, but looking at it in
sample time instead of looking
at the embedded queue.
Now the important thing here
is, when you look at it in
sample time, you might not
be able to do this.
Because with this entire
cannibal state Markov chain,
you might not be able to
define these self-loop
transition probabilities.
Because these numbers
might get too large.
But for the M/M/1 queue,
you can do it.
The important thing is that the
steady state probabilities
you find for these states are
not the same as the steady
state probabilities you find for
the embedded Markov chain.
They are in fact the same as the
steady state probabilities
for the Markov process itself.
That's these steady state
probabilities are the fraction
of time that you spend
in state j.
And this is a sample time
Markov process.
It is the same fraction of time
you spend in state j.
Here you have this
embedded chain.
And for example, in the embedded
chain, the only place
you go from state
0 is state 1.
Here from state 0, you
can stay in state
0 for a long time.
Because here the increments
of time are constant.
We can look at delayed renewal
reward theorems for the
renewal process to see what's
going on here, for the
fraction of time we
spend in state j.
We look at that picture
up there.
We start out in state
j, for example.
Same as the renewal reward
process that we had for a
Markov chain.
We got a reward of 1 for the
amount of time that we
stay in state j.
After that, we're wandering
around in the wilderness.
We finally come back
to state j again.
We get 1 unit of reward
times the amount of
time we spend here.
In other words, we're
accumulating reward at a rate
of 1 unit per unit time,
up to there.
So the average reward we get per
unit time is the expected
value of U of j divided by the
expected interrenewal time,
which is 1 over mu j times the
expected time, from one
renewal to the next.
Which tells us that the fraction
of time we spend in
state j is equal to the fraction
of transitions that
go to state j, divided by the
rate at which we leave state
j, times the expected
number of overall
transitions per unit time.
This is an important result.
Because depending on what M sub
i is, depending on what
the number of transitions per
unit time is, it really tells
you what's going on.
Because all of these bizarre
Markov processes that we've
looked at are bizarre because of
the way that this behaves.
This can infinite or can be 0.
At this point, we've been
talking about the expected
number of transitions per unit
time as a random variable, as
a limit in probability
1, given that we
start in state i.
And suddenly, we see that it
doesn't depend on i at all.
So there is some number, M bar,
which is the expected
number of transitions per unit
time, which is independent of
what state we started in.
We call that M M bar instead
M sub I. And that's this
quantity here.
And what we get from that it
is the fraction of time we
spend in state j is
proportional to pi
j over mu sub j.
But since it has to add up to
1, we have to divide it by
this quantity here.
And this quantity here
is one over--
this is the expected number of
transitions per unit time.
And if we try to get the pi sub
j's from P sub j's, the
corresponding thing, as we find
out, the expected number
transitions per unit time as
a sum over i, P sub i,
times mu sub i.
You can play all sorts of games
with these equations.
And when you do so, all of those
things become evident.
I would advise you to just
cross this equation out.
I don't know what
it came from.
But it doesn't mean anything.
We spent a lot of time talking
about what happens when the
expected number of transitions
per unit time
is either 0 or infinity.
We had this case we looked at of
an M/M/1 type queue, where
the server got rattled
as time went on.
And the server got rattled
with more and
more customers waiting.
The customer's got discouraged
and didn't come in.
So we had a process where the
longer the queue got, the
longer time it took for
anything to happen.
So that as far as the embedded
Markov chain went,
everything was fine.
But then we looked at the
process itself, the time that
it took in each of these higher
order states was so
large, that, as a process,
it didn't make any sense.
So the P sub i's were all 0.
The pi sub i's all
looked fine.
And the other kind of cases,
where the expected number of
transitions per unit time
becomes infinite.
And that's just the opposite
kind of case, where, when you
get to the higher ordered
states, things start happening
very, very fast.
The higher ordered state you
go to, the faster the
transitions occur.
It's like a small child.
I mean, the more excited the
small child gets, the faster
things happen.
And the faster things
happen, the more
excited the child gets.
So pretty soon things are
happening so fast, the child
just collapses.
And if you're lucky,
the child sleeps.
So you can think
of it that way.
We talked about reversibility.
And reversibility for Markov
processes I think is somewhat
easier to see then
reversibility for Markov chains.
If you're dealing with a Markov
process, we're sitting
in state i for a while.
At some time we make
a transition.
We go to state j.
We sit there for a long time.
Then we go to state
k and so forth.
If we try to look at this
process coming back the other
way, we see that we're
in state k.
At a certain point, we
had a transition.
We had a transition
into state j.
And how long does it
take before that
transition is over?
We're in state j, so the amount
of time that it takes
is an exponentially distributed
random variable.
And it's exponentially
distributed with the same
amount of time, whether we're
coming in this way or whether
we're coming in this way.
And that's the notion
of reversibility.
It doesn't make any difference
whether you look at it from
right to left or from
left to right.
And in this kind of situation,
if you find the steady state
probabilities for these
transitions or you find the
steady state fraction of time
you spend in each state.
I mean, we just showed that if
you look at this process going
backwards, if you define all
the probabilities coming
backwards, the expected amount
of time that you spend in
state i or the rate for leaving
state i is independent
of right to left.
And a slightly more complicated
argument says the
P sub i's are the same
going right to left.
And the fraction of time you
spend in each state is
obviously the same going
from right to left as
these limits occur.
So that gives you all these
bizarre conditions for
queuing, which are
very useful.
I'm not going to say any
more about that except
the guessing theorem.
The guessing theorem says
suppose a Markov process is
irreducible.
You can check pretty
easily whether it's
irreducible or not.
You can't necessarily
check very easily
whether it's recurrent.
And suppose P sub i is a set
of probabilities that
satisfies P sub i times
Q sub ij equals P sub
j times Q sub ji.
In other words, this is the
probability of being in state
i, and the next transition
is to state j.
This is the probability of being
in state j, and the next
transition to state i.
This says that if you can find
a set of probabilities which
satisfy these equations, and
if they also satisfy this
condition, P sub i, mu sub i,
less than infinity, then P sub
i is greater than 0 for all i.
P sub i is a steady state time
averaged probability state i.
The processes is reversible.
And the embedded chain is
positive recurring.
So all you have to do is
solve those equations.
And if you can solve those
equations, you're done.
Everything is fine.
You don't have to know anything
about reversibility
or renewal theory or
anything else.
If you have that theorem,
you just
solve for those equations.
Solve these equations by
guessing what the solution is,
and then you in fact have
a reversible process.
So the useful application of
this is that all birth-death
processes are reversible if this
equation is satisfied.
And you can immediately
find the steady state
probabilities of them.
I'm not going to have much
time for random walks.
But random walks are
what we've been
talking about all term.
We just didn't call them random
walks until we got to
the seventh chapter.
But a random walk is a sequence
of random variables,
where each Sn in the sequence
is a sum of some number of
underlying IID random variables,
X1 up to X sub n.
Well we're interested in
exponential bounds on S sub n
for large n.
These are known as
Chernoff bounds.
We talked about them back
in chapter one.
I'm not going to mention
them again now.
We're interested in threshold
crossings.
If you have two thresholds, one
positive threshold, one
negative threshold, you would
like to know what's the
stopping time when S sub
n first crosses alpha?
Or what's the stopping time when
it first crosses beta?
What's the probability of
crossing alpha before you
cross beta or vice versa?
And what's the distribution of
the overshoot, when you pass
one of them?
So there all those questions.
We pretty much talked
about the first two.
The question of overshoot,
I think I mentioned this.
The text doesn't say
much about it.
Overshoot is just a nasty,
nasty problem.
If you ever have to find the
overshoot of something, go
look for a computer program to
simulate it or something.
You're not going to solve
the problem very easily.
Fowler is the only book I know
which does a reasonable job of
trying to solve this.
And you have to be
extraordinarily patient.
I mean Fowler does everything
in the nicest possible way.
Or at least he always seem to
do everything in the nicest
possible way.
Most textbooks you look at,
after you understand the
subject, you look at and you
say, oh, he should have done
it this way.
I've never had that experience
with Fowler at all.
Always, I look at it.
I say, oh, there's an
easier way to do it.
I try to do it the easier way.
And then I find something's
wrong with it.
And then I go back and say,
ah, I got to do it the way
Fowler did it.
So if you're serious about this
field and you don't have
a copy of this very
old book, get it,
because it's solid gold.
Suppose a random variable has a
moment generating function,
expected value of E to
the zr over some
positive region of r.
And suppose it has a mean
which is negative.
The Chernoff bound says that for
any alpha greater than 0
and any r in 0 to r plus, the
probability that Z is greater
than or equal to alpha is
less than or equal to
this quantity here.
You remember, we derived this.
The derivation is very simple.
It's a an obvious result.
It's a little strange.
Because this says that for
this random variable it's
complimentary distribution
function has to go down as e
to the minus r alpha.
Now all random variables can't
go down exponentially as e to
the minus r alpha.
The reason for this is that
these moment generating
functions down exist
for all alpha.
So what it's really saying is
where it exists, it goes down
with alpha as e to the
minus r alpha.
We then define the
semi-invariant moment
generating function.
And then a more convenient way
of stating the Chernoff bound
was in this way.
You look here.
And you say, for a fixed value
of n here, this probability of
S sub n is greater than or equal
to n a, is something
which is going down
exponentially with n.
And if you optimize over
r, this bound is
exponentially tight.
In other words, if you try to
replace this with anything
smaller, namely which goes down
faster, than for large
enough n, the bound
will be false.
So this is the tightest bound
you can get when you
optimize it over r.
So its exponential in n.
Mostly we wanted to use it
for threshold crossings.
And for threshold crossings, we
would like to look at it in
another way.
And we dealt with this
graphically.
Probability of Sn greater
than or equal to alpha.
Now what we want to do is
hold alpha constant.
Alpha is some threshold
up there.
We want to ask, what's the
probability that after n
trials, we're sitting
above alpha?
And we'd like to try
to solve that for
different values of n.
The Chernoff bound, in this
case, this quantity here is
this intercept here.
You take the semi-invariant
moment
generating function as convex.
You draw this curve.
You take a tangent of
slope alpha over n.
And you see where
it hits here.
And this is the exponent
that you have.
This is a negative exponent.
As you very n, this tilts
around on this curve.
And it comes in to this point.
It goes back out again.
That's what happens to it.
And that smallest exponent, as
you vary n, is the most likely
time at which you're going
to cross that threshold.
And what we found,
from looking at
Wald's equality is that--
let me go on, because we're
running out of time.
Wald's identity for two
thresholds says this.
And the corollary says, if the
underlying random variable is
less than 0, and if the
r at which the--
the second solution of
gamma of r equals 0.
You have this convex curve.
Gamma is always equal to 0.
There's some other value of r,
for which gamma is equal to 0.
And that's r star.
And this says that the
probability that we have
crossed alpha at time j, where
j is the time of first
crossing, is less than
or equal e to the
minus alpha r star.
This bound is tight also.
And that's a very nice result.
Because that just says that all
you got do is find r star.
And that tells you what the
probability of crossing a
threshold is.
And it's a very tight bound
if alpha is very large.
It doesn't make any difference
what the negative threshold
is, or whether it's
there or not.
This tells you the thing
you want to know.
I think I'm going to stop at
that point, because I have
been sort of rushing to
get to this point.
And it doesn't do any good
to keep rushing.
So thank you all for being
around all term.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.